welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and it's been a
roller coaster ride of a week for Marvel
fans with spider-man apparently being
taken out of the MCU completely with
Sony and Disney failing to reach a deal
on the character Tom Holland and zendaya
and followed Sony on Instagram Stanley's
daughter spoke out about the treatment
of her father's legacy and all in all
it's been a non-stop barrage of news
that was a bigger extinction-level event
than infinity war however it looks like
there's finally been an agreement met
and after Tom Holland posted a cryptic
image to Instagram that featured not
only him and Robert Downey jr. but also
both of them holding Iron Man and
spider-man figures with the caption we
did it mr. stark we also have news from
cosmic book news that there's been an
agreement met according to the New Deal
Disney is getting a six picture deal
with Tom Holland with an option for a
seventh there will be three more
spider-man films after spider-man 3
which will also create a new trilogy the
second trilogy will focus on Peter
Parker's college years including plans
for Peter to meet up and team up with
Firestar and Iceman of the x-men the
other three movies are two Avengers
films in which spider-man will have a
larger role and become friends with
Johnny Storm Marvel Studios Wilhelm and
co-financed old spider-man related
movies for 30% of full profits and Sony
would distribute but Disney will acquire
exclusive digital and online rights for
Disney Plus and affiliated TV networks
Marvel Studios Wilhelm & Co finance
spider-verse live-action spin-offs under
the same terms venom will relocate into
the MCU Sony will be given permission to
t be live-action programs based on
spider-verse properties and Disney wants
the new deal to be done before Saturdays
Marvel panel at d23 Expo the spider-man
is also apparently going to be part of
the d23 Expo panel though we will see if
that materializes this weekend in
addition to this if another company
purchased Sony such as Apple the full
rights of spider-man will go back to
Disney the prior deal fell through
because Disney wanted to finance the
movie in a 50/50 split
but from this take 50% of the box-office
however there were rumors of a 70/30
split which is apparently what has been
agreed on and I can't wait to see if the
entire deal is announced this weekend
honestly this is incredible news and I
think the outcry of the Internet has
gone a long way to help push this
through and make it so that Disney and
Sony both pay attention put their
differences to one side and do what's
best for the fans and both companies I
think both corporations would have been
in a worse off position had the deal
fallen through with Sony pretty much
having to star their own new universe
and Marvel no longer having the new face
of the MCU I'm so glad that they reached
agreement as the sheer negativity that's
been blasted towards both companies over
the last couple of days has seen a
dramatic decrease in their stocks which
will no doubt have helped this is
brilliant news and I can't wait to see
what films come down the line if this is
made official it's definitely given fans
across the world a lot of hope and hey
happy days happy hogan days happy hogan
and spiderman in the same movie again
yeah obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on this news and if you're as
hype for it as I am
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my reaction
to the original news which should be
posted at the end you want to come talk
to me about movies TV shows games and
comic books then you can follow me on
Twitter a definition whitey it's the
best way to get in touch with me and
it's the perfect place to suggest new
videos and content so hopefully I see it
over there after this also just wanna
let you know that we're giving away a
free copy of John wick 3 on blu-ray and
all you have to do to be in with the
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave your thoughts on the
Sony Disney news in the comment section
below
the winner will be chosen at random on
September the 10th and the blu-ray will
be shipped out from then to ever get
surprised it's the best of luck that
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time
take a piece
[Music]